[موسيقى]
القانون في فرنسا يحدد ساعات الدوام ويمنع
ان يعمل الموظف اكثر من 48 ساعه في
الاسبوع لكن في حاله العمل بالاسود يختلف
الوضع كليا فصاحب العمل هو من يفرض ساعاته
بدون قيود متجاهلا بذلك حجم الجهد وقدره
الشخص على التحمل
العمل لفتره طويله يمكن ان يضر بصحه العمل
وفقا لدراسه اجرتها منظمه الصحه العالميه
نشرت في 2021 فالعمل اكثر من 55 ساعه في
الاسبوع يزيد من خطر الوفاه الناجمه عن
امراض القلب والسكته الدماغيه
[موسيقى]
قال له رب العالمين احسن من البشر بدون
اوراق
تشتغل يا
مع السلامه
وانت عندك عائله
[موسيقى]
لم يقتصر بحثنا على المناطق التي يكثر
فيها تواجد المهاجرين بل ذهبنا الى ابعد
منها حتى وصلنا الى جده
الشارع الاكثر شهره في فرنسا حيث توحي
مظاهر الترف هنا انا لا مكان لتلك
الانتهاكات هل العمل بالاسود منتشر باحياء
معينه في باريس مثلا الاحياء شعبيه
وبالحياه الراقي بنفس الوقت هلا نحن في
محل هون مطعم ومالها اشتغلت فيه لمده شهر
بالاسود بنفس الوقت في عندك منطقه
16 كمان بنفس الوقت فيها مطاعم كثير
وفيها شغل بالاسود الشغل بالاسود موجود
بكل مكان فيه مطاعم مباراه الاهلي يعني
موجود كل الاحياء بفرنسا
[موسيقى]
يلاحق المهاجرين في اماكن عملهم لا يفرق
كثيرا بين من لديه اوراق او لا فهذا الشاب
لاجئ سوري لم يحميه وضعه النظامي في البلد
من الوقوع في فخ بعض المحتالين
عرض علي انه نشتغل سوا ونفتح هذا المحل
بعد اول شهر قال لي انه امه مرضت فاضطر
انه يسافر اعطاني مفتاح البيت من فضيحه
المطعمته لحتى يكون في بيناتنا الثقه على
اساس بعد ثلاثه اشهر رجع هو شخص من
السفاره اساس المصارف بخير
قلت يعني مشي الحال قال لي خذ اجازه اسبوع
وبترجع على الشغل
صاحب المطعم استغل جهل شاب قوانين العمل
واجعله يوقع على عقد وهمي ولان الاثباتات
لم تكن كافيه للمحكمه علقت القضيه دون حكم
على رب العمل